the following is a conversation with
michael i
jordan a professor at berkeley and one
of the most
influential people in the history of
machine learning statistics
and artificial intelligence he has been
cited over 170 thousand times
and has mentored many of the world-class
researchers defining the field
of ai today including andrew eng
zubin garamani bentascar and
yoshio banjo all this
to me is as impressive as the over 32
000 points and the six nba championships
of the michael
j jordan of basketball fame
there's a non-zero probability that i
talked to the other michael jordan
given my connection to and love the
chicago bulls of the 90s
but if i had to pick one i'm going with
the michael jordan
of statistics and computer science or as
john le [ __ ] calls him
the miles davis of machine learning
in his blog post titled artificial
intelligence the revolution hasn't
happened yet
michael argues for broadening the scope
or the artificial intelligence field
in many ways the underlying spirit of
this podcast
is the same to see artificial
intelligence
as a deeply human endeavor to not only
engineer
algorithms and robots but to understand
and empower human beings
at all levels of abstractions from the
individual
to our civilization as a whole this
is the artificial intelligence podcast
if you enjoy it
subscribe on youtube give it five stars
at apple podcast
support it on patreon or simply connect
with me on twitter
at lex friedman spelled friday
as usual i'll do one or two minutes of
ads now and never any ads in the middle
that can break the flow of the
conversation
i hope that works for you and doesn't
hurt the listening experience
this show is presented by cash app the
number one finance app in the app store
when you get it use code lex podcast
cash app unless you send money to
friends buy bitcoin
and invest in the stock market with as
little as one dollar
since cash app does fractional share
trading let me mention
that the order execution algorithm that
works behind the scenes
to create the abstraction of the
fractional orders
is to me an algorithmic marvel so big
props for the cash app engineers
for solving a hard problem that in the
end provides an easy interface
that takes a step up to the next layer
of abstraction over the stock market
making trading more accessible for new
investors
and diversification much easier
so once again if you get cash app from
the app store or google play
and use the code lex podcast you'll get
ten dollars
and cash app will also donate ten
dollars the first one of my favorite
organizations that is helping to advance
robotics and stem education for young
people
around the world and now here's my
conversation
with michael i jordan
given that you're one of the greats in
the field of ai machine learning
computer science and so on
you're trivially called the michael
jordan of machine learning
although as you know you were born
first so technically mj is the michael i
jordan of basketball but
anyway my my favorite is yan la [ __ ]
calling you the miles davis
of machine learning because as he says
you reinvent yourself periodically and
sometimes leave
fans scratching their heads after you
change direction so
can you put at first your historian hat
on
and give a history of computer science
and ai as you saw it
as you experienced it including
the four generations of ai successes
that i've seen you talk about
sure yeah first of all i much prefer
yon's
metaphor um miles davis is uh was
a real explorer in jazz and um he had a
coherent story so i think i have one and
but it's not just the one you live
it's the one you think about later what
a good historian does is they
look back and they revisit um i think
what happening right now
is not ai that was an intellectual
aspiration
um that's still alive today is an
aspiration
but i think this is akin to the
development of chemical engineering
from chemistry or electrical engineering
from from electromagnetism
so if you go back to the 30s or 40s
there wasn't yet chemical engineering
there was chemistry there was fluid flow
there was
mechanics and so on but people
pretty clearly viewed interesting goals
try to build factories that
you make chemicals products and do it
viably safely
make good ones do it at scale
so people started to try to do that of
course and some factories worked some
didn't
you know some were not viable some
exploded but in parallel
developed a whole field called chemical
engineering right and chemical
engineering is a field it's it's no
no bones about it it has theoretical
aspects to it it has
practical aspects it's not just
engineering quote unquote it's
the real thing real concepts are needed
same thing with
electrical engineering you know there
was maxwell's equations which in some
sense
were everything you know about
electromagnetism but you needed to
figure out how to build circuits how to
build modules how to put them together
how to bring electricity from one point
to another
safely and so on so forth so whole field
is developed called electrical
engineering
all right i think that's what's
happening right now is that we have we
have a proto
field which is statistics compute more
the theoretical side of the algorithmic
side of computer science
that was enough to start to build things
but what things systems
that bring value to human beings and use
human data and mix in human decisions
the engineering side of that is all ad
hoc
that's what's emerging in fact if you
want to call machine learning a field
i think that's what it is that's a proto
form of engineering based on statistical
and computational ideas of previous
generations
but do you think there's something
deeper about ai in his dreams and
aspirations
as compared to chemical engineering and
electrical engineering well the dreams
and aspirations maybe but those are from
those are
500 years from now i think that that's
like the greek sitting there and saying
it would be neat to get to the moon
someday
right um i hate we have no clue how the
brain does computation uh we're just a
clueless we're like we're even worse
than the greeks
almost anything interesting uh
scientifically of our era
can you linger on that just for a moment
because you stand
not completely unique but a little bit
unique in that in the clarity of that
can you can you elaborate your intuition
of
why we like where we stand in our
understanding of the human brain
and a lot of people say you know
scientists say we're not very far in
understanding human brain
but you're like you're saying we're in
the dark here well i know i'm not unique
i don't even think in the clarity but if
you talk to real neuroscientists that
really study real
synapses or real neurons they agree they
agree it's a hundred year hundreds of
year
tasks and they're building it up slowly
surely
what the signal is there is not clear we
think we have all of our metaphors
we think it's electrical maybe it's
chemical it's a whole soup
it's ions and proteins and it's a cell
and that's even around like a single
synapse if you look at a
electromicrograph of a single synapse
it's a it's a city of its own
and that's one little thing on a
dendritic tree which is extremely
complicated you know electrochemical
thing
and it's doing these spikes and voltages
have been flying around and then
proteins are taking that and
taking it down into the dna and who
knows what so it is the
problem of the next few centuries it is
fantastic but we have our metaphors
about it is it an economic device is it
like the immune system or is it like a
layered
you know set of copy you know arithmetic
computations what
we have all these metaphors and they're
fun but that's not
real science per se there is
neuroscience that's not neuroscience
all right that that's that's like the
greek speculating about how to get to
the moon
fun right and i think that i like to say
this fairly strongly because i think a
lot of young people think we're on the
verge
because a lot of people who don't talk
about it clearly let it be
understood that yes we kind of this is
brain inspired we're kind of
close you know breakthroughs are on the
horizon
and unscrupulous people sometimes who
need money for their labs
um as i'm saying scrupulous but people
will oversell um i need money from a lab
i'm gonna
i'm studying here you know computational
neuroscience
um i'm gonna oversell it and so there's
been too much of that
so i'll step into the slight the gray
area between metaphor and engineering
with uh i'm not sure if you're familiar
with
brain computer interfaces so a company
like elon musk has neural link
that's working on putting electrodes
into the brain and trying to be able to
read both read
and send electrical signals just as you
said
even the basic mechanism of
communication
in the brain is not something we
understand but
do you hope without understanding the
fundamental principles of how the brain
works
we'll be able to do something
interesting
at that gray area of metaphor it's not
my area so i i hope
in the sense like anybody else hopes for
some interesting things to happen from
research
i would expect more something like
alzheimer's will get figured out from
modern neuroscience that you know a lot
of there's a lot of human suffering
based on brain disease
and we throw things like lithium at the
brain it kind of works no one has a clue
why
that's not quite true but you know
mostly we don't know and that's even
just about the biochemistry of the brain
and how it leads to mood swings and so
on how thought emerges from that
we just we were really really completely
dim
so that you might want to hook up
electrodes and try to do some signal
processing on that and try to find
patterns
fine you know by all means go for it
it's just not scientific at this point
it's just it's so it's like kind of
sitting in a satellite and watching the
emissions
from a city and trying to affirm things
about the micro economy even though you
don't have microeconomic concepts
i mean it's really that kind of thing
and so yes can you find some signals
that do something interesting or useful
can you control a cursor or mouse
with your brain yeah absolutely you know
and then
i can imagine business models based on
that and even
you know medical applications of that
but from there to understanding
algorithms that allow us to
really tie in deeply to from the brain
to computer you know i just no i don't
agree with elon musk i don't think
that's even that's not for our
generation it's not even for the century
so just uh in hopes of getting you to
dream
uh you've mentioned kolmogorov and
touring might pop
up do you think that there might be
breakthroughs
they'll get you to sit back in five ten
years and say
wow oh i'm sure there will be but i
don't think
that there'll be demos that impress me
i don't think that having a computer
call a restaurant and pretend to be a
human
is a breakthrough and people you know
some people present it as such
it's imitating human intelligence it's
even putting coughs
in the thing to make a bit of a pr stunt
and so
fine the world runs on those things too
and i don't want to diminish all the
hard work and engineering that goes
behind things like that and
and the ultimate value to the human race
but that's not scientific understanding
and and i know the people who work on
these things they are after a scientific
understanding
you know in the meantime they've got to
kind of you know the trains got to run
and they got miles to feed and they got
things to do
and there's nothing wrong with all that
i would call that though just
engineering and i want to distinguish
that between an engineering field like
electoral internet chemical injury that
originally that originally
emerged that had real principles and you
really knew what you're doing and you
had a little scientific understanding
maybe not even complete so it became
more predictable and it was
really gave value to human life because
it was understood
and and so we have to we don't want to
muddle too much these waters of
you know what we're able to do versus
what we really can do in a way that's
going to impress the next
so i don't i don't need to be wowed but
i i think that someone comes along in 20
years
a younger person who's absorbed all the
uh
the technology and for them to be wowed
i think they have to be more deeply
impressed a young kulmogorov would not
be wowed by some of the stunts that you
see right now coming from the big
companies the demos but do you think the
breakthroughs from kolmogorov
would be and give this question a chance
do you think they'll be in the
scientific
fundamental principles arena or do you
think it's possible to have fundamental
breakthroughs in engineering
meaning you know i would say some of the
things that elon musk is working with
spacex
and then others sort of trying to
revolutionize the fundamentals of
engineering of manufacturing of
of saying here's a problem we know how
to do a demo of and actually taking it
to scale
yeah so so there's going to be all kinds
of breakthroughs i just don't like that
terminology i'm a scientist and i work
on things day in and day out and things
move along and eventually
say wow something happened but it's i
don't like that language very much
also i don't like to prize theoretical
breakthroughs over practical ones
um i tend to be more of a theoretician
and i think there's lots to do in that
arena right now um and so i wouldn't
point to the komo gurus i might point to
the edisons of the era and maybe musk is
a bit more like that
but um you know musk god bless him also
we'll say things about ai that he knows
very little about
and and he doesn't know what he's he he
is you know leads people astray when he
talks about things he doesn't know
anything about
trying to program a computer to
understand natural language to be
involved in a dialogue
we're having right now that can happen
in our lifetime you could fake it
you can mimic sort of take old sentences
that humans use and retread them
with the deep understanding of language
now it's not going to happen and so from
that
you know i hope you can perceive that
the deeper yet deeper kind of aspects
and intelligence are not going to happen
now will there be breakthroughs you know
i think that google
was a breakthrough i think amazon's a
breakthrough you know i think uber is a
breakthrough you know that
bring value to human beings at scale in
new brand new ways based on data flows
and and so on
a lot of these things are slightly
broken because there's not a kind of a
engineering field that takes economic
value in context of data
and and at you know planetary scale and
and worries about
all the externalities the privacy you
know we don't have that field so we
don't think these things through very
well
but i see that is emerging and that will
be cons that will you know looking back
from 100 years that will be constituted
a breakthrough in this era just like
electrical engineering was a
breakthrough in the early part of the
last century and chemical injury was a
breakthrough
so the scale the markets that you talk
about and we'll get to
will be seen as sort of breakthrough and
we're in the very early days of really
doing
interesting stuff there and we'll get to
that but it's just taking a quick step
back
can you give uh we kind of threw off the
historian hat
i mean you briefly said that uh in
the history of ai kind of mimics the
history of chemical engineering
but i keep saying machine learning you
keep want to say ai just to let you know
i don't you know i
i'd resist that i don't think this is
about ai really was john mccarthy
as almost a philosopher saying wouldn't
it be cool if we could put thought in a
computer
if we could mimic the human capability
to think or
put intelligence in in some sense into a
computer
that's an interesting philosophical
question and he wanted to make it more
than philosophy he wanted to actually
write down logical formula and
algorithms that would do that
and that is a perfectly valid reasonable
thing to do that's not what's happening
in this era
right so so the reason i keep saying ai
actually
and i'd love to hear what you think
about it machine learning has uh
has a very particular set of methods and
tools
maybe your version of it is that mine
doesn't no it does it's very very open
it does optimization it does sampling it
does
so systems that learn is what machine
learning is systems that learn and make
decisions
and make decisions so what is pattern
recognition and from you know
finding patterns it's all about making
decisions in real worlds and having
close feedback loops
so something like symbolic ai expert
systems reading systems knowledge based
representation
all of those kinds of things search does
that
neighbor fit into what you think of as
machine learning
so i don't even like the word but you
know i think that with the field you're
talking about is all about making large
collections of decisions under
uncertainty by large collections of
entities
yes right and there are principles for
that at that scale
you don't have to say the principles are
for a single entity that's making
decisions a single agent or a single
human
it really immediately goes to the
network of decisions is a good award for
that or no no there's no good words for
any of this that's kind of part of the
problem
um so we can continue the conversation
use ai for all that i just want to kind
of
raise our flag here that this is not
about
we don't know what intelligence is and
real intelligence we don't know much
about abstraction and reasoning at the
level of humans
we don't have a clue we're not trying to
build that because we don't have a clue
eventually it may emerge they'll make i
don't know if there'll be breakthroughs
but eventually we'll start to get
glimmers of that it's not what's
happening right now though
okay we're taking data we're trying to
make good decisions based on that we're
trying to scale we're trying to do it
economically viably we're trying to
build markets
we're trying to keep value at that scale
and
aspects of this will look intelligent it
will look computers were so dumb
before they will seem more intelligent
we will use that buzz word of
intelligence so we can use it in that
sense but
you know so machine learning you can
scope it narrowly is just learning from
data and pattern recognition
but whatever i when i talk about these
topics i maybe data science is another
word you could throw in the mix
it really is important that the
decisions are as part of it it's
consequential decisions in the real
world
are i have a medical operation am i
going to drive down the street
you know things that where their
scarcity things that
impact other human beings or other you
know the environment and so on
how do i do that based on data how do i
do that adaptively how i use computers
to help those kind of things go forward
whatever you want to call that
so let's call it ai let's agree to call
it ai but it's um
let's let's not say that what the goal
of that is
is intelligence the goal of that is
really good working systems at planetary
scale
we've never seen before so reclaiming
the word ai from the dartmouth
conference from many decades ago of the
dream of humanity i don't want to
reclaim it i want a new word i think it
was a bad choice i mean i i you know i
if you read one of my little things um
the history was basically that uh
mccarthy needed a new name because
cybernetics already existed
and he didn't like you know no one
really liked norbert wiener you know
ravina
was kind of an island to himself and he
felt that he had encompassed all this
and in some sense he did
you look at the language of cybernetics
it was everything we're talking about it
was control theory and single processing
and some notions of intelligence and
close feedback loops and data
it was all there it's just not a word
that lived on partly because of maybe
the personalities
but mccarthy needed a new word to say
i'm different from you i'm not part of
your your show
i got my own invented this word um
and again as a kind of a thinking
forward about the movies that would be
made about it
uh it was a great choice but thinking
forward about creating a sober academic
and real world discipline it was a
terrible choice because it led to
promises that are not true that we
understand
we understand artificial perhaps but we
don't understand intelligence
it's a small tangent because you're one
of the great personalities of machine
learning whatever the heck you call the
field
the do you think science progresses by
personalities or by the fundamental
principles and theories
and research that's outside of
personality
both and i wouldn't say there should be
one kind of personality i have mine
and i have my preferences and i have a
kind of network around me
that feeds me and and some of them agree
with me and some disagree but
all kinds of personalities are needed um
right now i think the personality that's
a little too exuberant a little bit too
ready to promise the moon
is a little bit too much in ascendance
um and i do
i do think that that's there's some good
to that it certainly attracts lots of
young people to our field
but a lot of those people come in with
strong misconceptions and they have to
then
unlearn those and then find something
you know
to do um and so i think there's just got
to be some
multiple voices and there's i didn't i
wasn't hearing enough of the more sober
voice
so uh as a continuation of a fun tangent
and speaking of vibrant personalities
what would you say is the most
interesting disagreement you have with
yon lacoon
so john's an old friend and i just say
that
i i don't think we disagree about very
much really
he and i both kind of have a let's build
that kind of mentality
and does it work kind of mentality and
uh kind of concrete
um we both speak french and we speak
french more together and we have we have
a lot a lot in common
um and so you know if one wanted to
highlight a
a disagreement it's not really a
fundamental one i think it's just kind
of
where we're emphasizing um jan has
uh emphasized pattern recognition and
uh has emphasized prediction all right
so
you know um and it's interesting to try
to take that as far as you can if you
could do perfect prediction what would
that give you kind of as a thought
experiment
um and um i think that's
way too limited um we cannot do perfect
prediction we will never have the data
sets allow me to figure out what you're
about ready to do what question you're
going to ask next i have no clue i will
never know
such things moreover most of us find
ourselves
during the day in all kinds of
situations we had no anticipation of
that are kind of very
very novel in various ways and
in that moment we want to think through
what we want and also there's going to
be market forces acting on us
i'd like to go down that street but now
it's full because there's a crane in the
street i gotta i gotta think about that
i gotta
think about what i might really want
here and i gotta sort of think about how
much it cost me to do this action versus
this action
i got to think about the risks involved
you know a lot of our current pattern
recognition and prediction systems don't
do any risk
evaluations they have no error bars
right i got to think about other
people's decisions around me i got to
think about a collection of my decisions
even just thinking about like a medical
treatment you know i'm not going to take
the prediction of a neural net about my
health
about something consequential am i about
to have a heart attack because some
number is over 0.7
even if you had all the data in the
world never been collected about heart
attacks
better than any doctor ever had i'm not
going to trust the output of that neural
net to predict my heart attack
i'm going to want to ask what if
questions around that i'm going to want
to look at some us or other possible
data i didn't have
causal things i'm going to have a
dialogue with a doctor about things we
didn't think about we gathered the data
you know it i could go on and on i hope
you can see and i don't i think that if
you say predictions everything
that that you're missing all of this
stuff
and so prediction plus decision making
is everything but both of them are
equally important
and so the field has emphasized
prediction yan rightly so has seen how
powerful that is
but at the cost of people not being
aware that decision making is where the
rubber really hits the road where human
lives are at stake where risks are being
taken where you got to gather more data
you got to think about the arab bars you
got to think about the consequences of
your decisions on others you about the
economy around your decisions blah blah
blah
i'm not the only one working on those
but we're a smaller tribe and right now
we're not
the the one that people talk about the
most um
but you know if you go out in the real
world in industry um you know
at amazon i'd say half the people there
are working on decision making and the
other half are doing you know the
pattern recognition
it's important and the words of pattern
recognition and prediction i think the
distinction there
not to linger on words but the
distinction there is more a constrained
sort of
in the lab data set versus decision
making is talking about consequential
decisions
in the real world under the messiness
and the uncertainty of the real world
and just the whole of it the whole mess
of it that actually touches human beings
and scale like you said market forces
that's the that's the distinction yeah
it helps add those that perspective that
broader perspective
you're right i totally agree uh on the
other hand if you're a real prediction
person of course you want it to be in
the real world you want to predict real
world events i'm just saying that's not
possible
with just data sets uh that it has to be
in the context of you know
uh strategic things that someone's doing
data they might gather
things they could have gathered the
reasoning process around data it's not
just taking data and making predictions
based on the data
so one of the the things that you're
working on
i'm sure there's others working on it
but i don't hear often
it talked about especially in the
clarity that you talk about it
and i think it's both the most exciting
and the most concerning
area of ai in terms of decision making
so you've talked about ai systems that
help make decisions that scale
in a distributed way millions billions
decisions
it's sort of markets of decisions can
you as a starting point sort of give an
example of a system that you think about
when you're thinking about these kinds
of systems
uh yeah so first of all you're
absolutely getting into some territory
which
i will be beyond my expertise and and
there are lots of things that are going
to be very non-obvious to think about
just like
just again i like to think about history
a little bit but think about put
yourself back in the 60s there was kind
of a banking system that wasn't
computerized really there was there was
database theory emerging and database
people had to think about how do i
actually not just move data around but
actual money
and have it be you know valid and have
transactions that atms happen that are
actually you know all valid and
so on so forth so that's the kind of
issues you get into when you start to
get serious about sort of things like
this
i like to think about as kind of almost
a thought experiment to help me think
uh something simpler which is a music
market
and uh because there is the first door
there is no music market
in the world right now or in the con in
our country for sure
uh there are uh something called things
called record companies
and they make money uh and they prop up
a few um
really good musicians and make them
superstars and they
all make huge amounts of money but
there's a long tale of huge numbers of
people that make lots and lots of really
good music that is actually listened to
by more people than the famous people
um
they are not in a market they cannot
have a career they do not make money
the creators the creators the creators
the so-called influencers or whatever
that diminishes who they are
right so there are people who make
extremely good music especially in the
hip-hop or latin
world these days uh they do it on their
laptop that's what they do
on the weekend and they have another job
during the week and they put it up on
soundcloud or other sites
eventually it gets streamed it down gets
turned into bits it's not economically
valuable
the information is lost it gets put up
there people stream it
you walk around in a big city you see
people with headphones all you know
especially young kids listen to music
all the time
if you look at the data none of them
very little the music they listen to is
the famous people's music and
none of it's old music it's all the
latest stuff but the people who made
that latest stuff are like some 16 year
old somewhere who will never make a
career out of this who will never make
money
of course there will be a few counter
examples the record companies
incentivize to pick out a few and
highlight them
long story short there's a missing
market there there is not a
consumer producer relationship at the
level of the actual creative acts
um the pipelines and spotifys of the
world that take this stuff and stream it
along
they make money off of subscriptions or
advertising and those things they're
making the money all right and then they
will offer bits and pieces of it to a
few people again to highlight that
you know they're they simulate a market
anyway a real market would be
if you're a creator of music that you
actually are somebody who's good enough
that people want to listen to you
you should have the data available to
you there should be a dashboard
showing a map of the united states so in
last week here's all the places your
songs were listened
to it should be transparent um
vettable so that if someone in down in
providence sees that
you're being listened to ten thousand
times in providence that they know
that's real data you know it's real data
they will have you come give a show down
there they will broadcast to the people
who've been listening to you that you're
coming
if you do this right you could you could
you know go down there make twenty
thousand dollars
you do that three times a year you start
to have a career so in this sense ai
creates jobs
it's not about taking away human jobs
it's creating new jobs because it
creates a new market
once you've created a market you've now
connected up producers and consumers
you know the new person who's making the
music can say to someone who comes to
their shows a lot hey i'll play your
daughter's wedding
for ten thousand dollars you'll say
eight thousand they'll say nine thousand
um then you again you you can now get an
income up to a hundred thousand dollars
you're not going to be a millionaire
all right and and now even think about
really the value of music is in these
personal connections even so much so
that um
a young kid wants to wear a t-shirt with
their favorite musician's signature on
it right
so if they listen to the music on the
internet the internet should be able to
provide them with a button as they push
and the merchandise arrives the next day
we can do that right and now
why should we do that well because the
kid who bought the shirt will be happy
but more the person who made the music
will get the money
there's no advertising needed right so
you could create
markets between personal consumers take
five percent cut
your company will be perfectly uh sound
it'll go forward into the future and it
will create new markets and that raises
human happiness
um now this seems like it was easy just
create this dashboard kind of create
some connections and all that but
you know if you think about uber or
whatever you think about the challenges
in the real world of doing things like
this and there are actually new
principles going to be needed
you're trying to create a new kind of
two-way market at a different scale
that's ever been done before there's
going to be
you know unwanted aspects of the market
there'll be bad people they'll be
you know the data will get used in the
wrong ways you know it'll fail in some
ways it won't deliver value you have to
think that through just like anyone who
like ran a big auction or you know
ran a big matching service in economics
will think these things through
and so that maybe doesn't get at all the
huge issues that can arise when you
start to create markets but it starts
for at least
for me solidify my thoughts and allow me
to move forward in my own thinking
yeah so i talked to how to research at
spotify actually
i think their long-term goal they've
said is to uh
have at least 1 million creators make a
make a comfortable living putting on
spotify
so in and
i think you articulate a really nice
vision
of uh the world and the digital and the
cyber space of markets
what what do you think companies like
spotify
or youtube or netflix
can do to create
such markets is it an ai problem is it
an interface problem so interface design
is it uh some other kind of it was an
economics problem
who should they hire to solve these
problems well part of it's not just top
down
so the silicon valley has its attitude
that they know how to do it they will
create the system just like google did
with the search box that will be so good
that they'll just everyone will adopt
that
right um it's not it's it's everything
you said but really i think missing the
kind of culture
all right so it's literally that 16 year
old who's able to create the songs
you don't create that as a silicon
valley entity you don't hire them
per se right you have to create an
ecosystem in which they are wanted
and that they belong right so you have
to have some cultural credibility to do
things like this
you know netflix to their credit wanted
some of that sort of credibility they
created
shows you know content they call it
content it's such a terrible word but
it's called it's culture
right and so with movies you can kind of
go give a large sum of money to somebody
graduate from the usc film school
it's a whole thing of its own but it's
kind of like rich white people's thing
to do
you know and you know american culture
has not been so much about rich white
people
it's been about all the immigrants all
the africans who came and brought
that culture and those those rhythms and
and that
that to to this world and created this
whole new thing you know
american culture and and so companies
can't artificially create that they
can't just say hey we're here
we're going to buy it up you got a
partner right and um
so but anyway you know not to integrate
these companies are all trying and they
should and they
they are i'm sure they're asking these
questions and some of them are even
making an effort but it is
it is partly a respect the culture as
you were as a technology person you got
to blend your technology with cultural
with cultural uh you know meaning how
much
of a role do you think the algorithm
machine learning has in connecting the
consumer to the creator
sort of uh the recommender system aspect
of this yeah it's a great question i
think pretty high recommend
you know um there's no magic in the
algorithms but a good recommender system
is way better than a bad recommender
system
and uh recommender systems was a billion
dollar industry back even
you know 10 20 years ago um and it
continues to be extremely important
going forward
what's your favorite recommender system
just so we can put something well just
historically i was one of the you know
when i first went to amazon and
you know i first didn't like amazon
because they put the book people out of
business or the library
you know the local book sellers went out
of business um
i've come to accept that they're you
know there probably are more books being
selled now and more people reading them
than
ever before and then local books stores
are coming back
so you know that's how economics
sometimes work you go up and you go down
but anyway when i finally started going
there and i bought a few books i was
really pleased to see another few books
being recommended to me that i never
would have thought of
and i bought a bunch of them so they
obviously had a good business model but
i learned things
and i still to this day kind of browse
using that service
um and i think lots of people get a lot
you know they're
that that is a good aspect of a
recommendation system i'm learning from
my peers
in a in an indirect way
and their algorithms are not meant to
have them impose what we what we learn
it really is trying to find out what's
in the data
uh it doesn't work so well for other
kind of entities but that's just the
complexity of human life like
shirts you know i'm not gonna get
recommendations on shirts and uh but
that's
that's that's interesting uh if you try
to recommend
um uh restaurants it's it's it's it's
it's
hard it's hard to do it at scale and and
um
but uh a blend of recommendation systems
with other
economic ideas matchings and so on is
really really still
very open research-wise and there's new
companies that could emerge that do that
well
what what do you think is going to the
messy difficult land of
say politics and things like that that
youtube and twitter have to deal with in
terms of recommendation systems
being able to suggest i think facebook
just launched facebook news
so they're having recommend the kind of
news that are most likely for you to be
interesting
you think this is this ai solvable again
whatever term want to use do you think
it's a solvable problem for machines or
is it a deeply human problem that's
unsolvable
uh so i don't even think about it that
level i think that what's broken with
some of these companies it's all
monetization by advertising
they're not at least facebook let's i
want to critique them they didn't really
try to connect a producer and a consumer
in an economic way
right no one wants to pay for anything
and so they all
you know starting with google and
facebook they went back to the playbook
of you know the
the television companies back in the day
no one wanted to pay for this signal
they will pay for the tv box but not for
the signal
at least back in the day and so
advertising kind of filled that gap but
advertising was new and interesting and
it somehow didn't take over our lives
quite
right fast forward google provides a
service that people don't want to pay
for
um and so somewhat surprising in the 90s
they made
end up making huge amounts they cornered
the advertising market it didn't seem
like that was going to happen at least
to me
um these little things on the right hand
side of the screen just did not seem all
that economically interesting but that
companies had maybe no other choice the
tv market was going away and billboards
and so on
um so they've they got it and i think
that sadly that uh google just has me it
was doing so well with that and making
such right they didn't think much more
about how wait a minute
is there a producer consumer
relationship to be set up here not just
uh between us and the advertisers
market to be created is there an actual
market between the producer and consumer
they're the producers the person who
created that video clip the person that
made that
website the person who could make more
such things the person who could adjust
it and as a function of demand
the person on the other side who's
asking for different kinds of things you
know so
you see glimmers of that now there's
influencers and there's kind of a little
glimmering of a market but it should
have been done 20 years ago it should
have been thought about it should have
been created in parallel with the
advertising ecosystem
and then facebook inherited that and i
think they also didn't think very much
about that
so fast forward and now they are making
huge amounts of money off of advertising
and the news thing and all these clicks
is just is feeding the advertising it's
all connected up to the advertiser
so you want more people to click on
certain things because that money flows
to you
facebook you're very much incentivized
to do that and when you start to find
it's breaking
people are telling you well we're
getting into some troubles you try to
adjust it with your smart ai
algorithms right and figure out what are
bad clicks though maybe shouldn't be
click-through rate it should be
something
i find that pretty much hopeless it does
get into all the complexity in life
and you can try to fix it you should but
you could also fix the whole business
model
and the business model is that really
what are are there some human producers
and consumers out there
is there some economic value to be
liberated by connecting them directly
is it such that it's so valuable that uh
people are willing to pay for it
all right and micro payments like smart
micro but even have to be micro
so i i like the example suppose i'm
going next week i'm going to india never
been to india before
right uh i have a couple days in in
mumbai
um i have no idea what to do there right
and i could go on the web right now and
search it's going to be kind of hopeless
i'm not going to find you know
um i'll have lots of advertisers in my
face right
what i really want to do is broadcast to
the world that i am going to mumbai
and have someone on the other side of a
market look at me and
and there's a recommendation system
there so i'm not looking at all possible
people coming to mumbai they're looking
at the people who are relevant to them
so someone my age group someone who kind
of
knows me in some level i give up a
little privacy by that but i'm happy
because what i'm going to get back is
this person's going to make a little
video for me
or they're going to write a little
two-page paper on here's the cool things
that you want to do and move by this
week especially
right i'm going to look at that i'm not
going to pay a micro payment i'm going
to pay you know 100
or whatever for that it's real value
it's like journalism um
as i'm not a subscription it's that i'm
gonna pay that person in that moment
company's gonna take five percent of
that and that person has now got it it's
a gig economy if you will but you know
done for in
you know thinking about a little bit
behind youtube there was actually people
who could make more of those
things if they were connected to a
market they would make more of those
things
independently you have to tell them what
to do you don't have to incentivize them
any other way
um and so yeah these companies i don't
think have thought long long and hard
about that so
i do distinguish on you know facebook on
the one side who just not thought about
these things at all i think
uh thinking that ai will fix everything
uh and amazon thinks about them all the
time because they were already out in
the real world they were delivering
packages people's doors they were they
were worried about a market they were
worrying about sellers and you know they
worry and
some things they do are great some
things maybe not so great but you know
they're in that business model and then
i'd say google sort of hover somewhere
in between
i don't i don't think for a long long
time they they got it
i think they probably see that youtube
is more pregnant with possibility than
than
than
they might have thought and that they're
probably heading that direction um
but uh you know silicon valley's been
dominated by the google facebook kind of
mentality and the subscription and
advertising and that is that's the core
problem
right the fake news actually rides on
top of that
because it means that you're monetizing
with click-through rate and that is the
core problem you got to remove that
so advertisement if you're going to
linger on that i mean that's an
interesting thesis i don't know if
everyone really deeply thinks about that
so you're right the thought is
the advertising model is the only thing
we have the only thing we'll ever have
so we have to fix we have to build
algorithms
that despite that business model
you know find the better angels of our
nature and do good by society and by the
individual
but you think we can slowly you think
first of all
there's a difference between should and
could so you're saying we
should slowly move away from the
advertising model and have a direct
connection between the consumer and the
creator
the the question i also have is can we
because the advertising model is so
successful
now in terms of just making a huge
amount of money
and therefore being able to build a big
company that provides has really smart
people working that
create a good service do you think it's
possible and just to clarify you think
we should
move away well i think we should yeah
but uh we is you know
me so society yeah will the companies um
i mean so first of all full disclosure
i'm doing a day a week at amazon because
i kind of want to learn more about how
they do things so you know i'm not
speaking for amazon in any way but
um you know i did go there because i
actually believe they get a little bit
of this are trying to create these
markets
and they don't really use advertising is
not a crucial part of it that's a good
question so
it has become not crucial but it's
become more and more present if you go
to amazon website
and you know without revealing too many
deep secrets about amazon i can tell you
that you know
a lot of people company question this
and there's a huge questioning going on
you do not want a world where there's
zero advertising that actually is a bad
world
okay so here's a way to think about it
you're
a company that like amazon is trying to
bring products to customers
all right and the customer at any given
you want to buy a vacuum cleaner say
you want to know what's available for me
and you know it's not gonna be that
obvious you have to do a little bit of
work at it
the recommendation system will sort of
help all right but now suppose this
other person over here has just made the
world you know they spent a huge amount
of energy they had a great idea they
made a great vacuum cleaner
they know they they really did it they
nailed it it's an mit you know
whiz kid that made a great new vacuum
cleaner all right it's not going to be
in the recommendation system
no one will know about it the algorithms
will not find it and ai will not fix
that
okay at all right how do you allow that
vacuum cleaner to start to get
in front of people be sold well
advertising and here what advertising is
it's a signal
that you're you believe in your product
enough that you're willing to pay some
real money for it
and to me as a consumer i look at that
signal i say well first of all i know
these are not just cheap little ads
because we have now right now i know
that you know these are super cheap you
know
pennies uh if i see an ad where it's
actually i know the company is only
doing a few of these and they're making
you know
real money is kind of flowing and i see
an ad i may pay more attention to it and
i actually might want that
because i see hey that guy spent money
on his vacuum cleaner
or maybe there's something good there so
i will look at it and and so that's part
of the overall information flow in a
good market
uh so advertising has a role um
but the problem is of course that that
signal is now completely gone
because it just you know dominar by
these tiny little things that add up to
big money
for the company you know so i i think it
will just
i think it will change because the
societies just don't you know stick with
things that
annoy a lot of people and advertising
currently annoys people more than it
provides information
and i think that at google probably is
smart enough to figure out that this is
a dead this is a bad model
even though it's a hard huge amount of
money and they'll have to figure out how
to pull it away from it and slowly
and i'm sure the ceo there will figure
it out but um
they need to do it and uh they need to
so if you reduce advertising not to zero
but you reduce it at the same time you
bring up
producer consumer actual real value
being delivered so real money is being
paid and they take a five percent cut
that five percent could start to get big
enough to cancel out the lost revenue
from the the kind of the poor kind of
advertising and i think that a good
company will
will do that we'll realize that um and
they're com you know facebook you know
again god bless them they they bring you
know grandmother's
uh you know uh they bring children's
pictures into grandmother's lives it's
fantastic
um but they need to think of a new
business model
and and they that's that's the core
problem there um until they start to
connect producer consumer i think they
will just
just continue to make money and then buy
the next social network company and then
buy the next one
and the innovation level will not be
high and the health the
health issues will not go away so i
apologize that we kind of return to
words i don't think the exact terms
matter but
in sort of defensive advertisement
don't you think the kind of direct
connection between consumer
and creator producer
is the best like the
is what advertisement strives to do
right so that is the best advertisement
is literally now
facebook is listening to our
conversation and heard that you're going
to india
and we'll be able to actually start
automatically for you making these
connections
and start giving this offer so like i
apologize if it's just a matter of terms
but just to draw a distinction is it
possible to make advertisements just
better and better and better
algorithmically to where
it actually becomes a connection almost
address that's a good question so let's
component all that
push first of all i i what we just
talked about i was defending advertising
okay so i was defending it as a way to
get signals into a market that don't
come any other way
especially algorithmically it's a sign
that someone spent money on it it's a
sign they think it's valuable
and if i think that if other things
someone else thinks it's valuable
and if i trust other people i might be
willing to listen i don't trust that
facebook though is who's an intermediary
between this
i don't think they care about me okay
i don't think they do and i find it
creepy that they know i'm going to india
next week because of our conversation
why do you think that
can we so what can you just put your pr
hat on
why do you think you find facebook uh
creepy and not trust them as
as do majority of the population so
they're
out of the silicon valley companies i
saw like not approval rate but there's
there's ranking of how much people trust
companies and facebook is in in the
gutter
in the gutter including people inside of
facebook so what
uh what do you attribute that to because
when i come on you don't find it creepy
that right now we're talking i might
walk out on the street right now that
some unknown person who i don't know
kind of comes up to me and says i hear
you going to india i mean that's not
even facebook that's just a
if i want transparency in human society
i want to have if you know something
about me there's actually some reason
you know something about me
that's something that if i look at it
later and audit it kind of i approve
you know something about me because you
care in some way there's a caring
relationship
even or an economic one or something not
just that you're someone who could
exploit it in ways i don't
know about or care about or or i'm
troubled by or or whatever
and we're in a world right now where
that happens way too much
and that facebook knows things about a
lot of people and
could exploit it and does exploit it at
times i think most people do find that
creepy it's not for them it's not
it's not that it's facebook that's not
doing it because they care about them
right in any real sense and they
shouldn't they should not be a big
brother caring about us that is not the
role of a company like that
why not wait not the big brother part
but the sharing the trust thing i mean
don't those companies just to linger
because a lot of companies have a lot of
information about us
i would argue that there's companies
like microsoft that has more information
about us
than facebook does and yet we trust
microsoft more well microsoft is
pivoting
microsoft you know under satya nadella
has decided this is really important
we don't want to do creepy things we
really want people to trust us to
actually only use information in ways
that they really would approve of that
we don't decide
right and um i'm just kind of adding
that the health the health of a market
is that
uh when i connect to someone who
produces a consumer it's not just a
random producer consumer it's
people who see each other they don't
like each other but they sense that if
they transact
some happiness will go up on both sides
if a company helps me to do that
and moments that i choose of my choosing
then fine so and also think about the
difference between you know
browsing versus buying right there are
moments in my life i just want to buy
you know a gadget or something i need
something for that moment i need some
ammonia for my house or something
because i got a problem
a spill i want to just go in i don't
want to be advertised
at that moment i don't want to be led
down very dire you know that's annoying
i want to just go and have it
extremely easy to do what i want um
other moments i might say no it's like
today i'm going to the shopping mall
i want to walk around and see things and
see people and be exposed to stuff so i
want control over that though i don't
want the company's algorithms to decide
for me
right and i think that's the thing we
it's a total loss of control if facebook
thinks they should take the control from
us
of deciding when we want to have certain
kinds of information when we don't what
information that is
how much it relates to what they know
about us that we didn't really want them
to know about us
they're not i don't want them to be
helping me in that way i don't want them
to be helping them but they decide
well they have control over um um what i
want and when
i totally agree so facebook by the way i
have this optimistic thing where
i think facebook has the kind of
personal information about us
that could create a beautiful thing so i
i'm really optimistic
of what facebook could do uh it's not
what it's doing but what it could do
so i don't see that i think that
optimism is misplaced
because there's not a bit you have to
have a business model behind these
things yes
create a beautiful thing is really let's
be let's be clear
it's about something that people would
value and and i don't think they have
that business model
and i don't think they they will
suddenly discover it by what you know
have
a long hot shower i disagree i disagree
in terms of uh you can discover a lot of
amazing things
in the shower so if i didn't say that i
said they won't come they won't they
won't do it
but in the shower i think a lot of other
people will discover it i think that
this guy so i should also
uh full disclosure there's a company
called united masters which i'm on their
board and they've created this music
market
yes they have a hundred thousand artists
now signed on and they've done things
like gone to the nba
and the nba the music you find behind me
the eclipse right now is their music
right that's a company that had the
right business model in mind from the
get-go
right executed on that and and from day
one there was value brought to
so here you have a kid who made some
songs who suddenly their songs are on
the nba website
right that that's real economic value to
people
and uh so you know so you and i differ
on the optimism of being able to
sort of uh um change the direction of
the titanic
right so i yeah i'm older than you so i
think
titanic's crash got it
but uh so and just to elaborate because
i totally agree with you and i just want
to know how difficult you think this
problem is of
so for example i um i want to read some
news
and i would there's a lot of times in
the day where something makes me either
smile
or think in a way where i like
consciously think this really gave me
value
like i sometimes listen to uh the daily
podcast in the new york times
way better than the new york times
themselves by the way for people
listening that's like real journalism is
happening for some reason in the podcast
space it doesn't make sense to me
but often i'll listen to it 20 minutes
and i
i would be willing to pay for that like
five dollars ten dollars for that
experience absolutely
and how difficult that's kind of what
you're
getting at is that little transaction
how difficult is it to create a
frictionless system like uber has for
example
for other things what's your intuition
there uh so i first of all
i pay little bits of money to you know
to say there's something called courts
that does financial things i like medium
as a site i don't pay there but
um i would you had a great post on
medium
i would have loved to pay you a dollar
and but i wouldn't
want it i wouldn't have wanted it per se
because um
there should be also sites where that's
not actually the goal the goal is to
actually have a broadcast channel
that i monetize in some other way if i
chose to i mean i could
now people know about it i could i'm not
doing it but um
that's fine with me there also the
musicians who are making all this music
i don't think the right model is that
you pay a little subscription fee
to them all right because because people
can copy the bits too easily and it's
just not that somewhere the value is the
value is that a connection was made
between real human beings then you can
follow up on that
right and create yet more value so no i
think um
there's a lot of open questions here hot
open questions but also yeah i do want
good recommendation systems that
recommend
cool stuff to me and but it's pretty
hard right i don't like them to
recommend stuff just based on my
browsing history
i don't like that based on stuff they
know about me quote quote what's unknown
about me is the most interesting
so this is the this is the really
interesting question we may disagree
maybe not
i think that i love recommender systems
and i want to give them everything about
me in a way that i trust
yeah but you but you don't because so
for example this morning i clicked on i
you know i was pretty sleepy this
morning um i
clicked on a story about the queen of
england yes
right i do not give a damn about the
queen of england i really do not but it
was clickbait it kind of looked
funny and i had to say what the heck are
they talking about i don't want to have
my life
you know heading that direction now
that's in my browsing history
the system in any reasonable system
we'll think about
history right but but you're saying all
the trace all the digital exhaust or
whatever that's been kind of the models
if you collect all this stuff
you're gonna figure all of us out well
if you're trying to figure out like kind
of one person like trump or something
maybe you could figure him out
but if you're trying to figure out you
know 500 million people
you know no way no way do you think so
no i do
i think so i think we are humans are
just amazingly rich and complicated
every one of us has our little quirks
everyone else has our little things that
could intrigue us that we don't even
know and will intrigue us
and there's no sign of it in our past
but by god there it comes and
you know you fall in love with it and i
don't want a company trying to figure
that out for me and anticipate that okay
well
i want them to provide a forum a market
a place that i kind of go
and by hook or by crook this happens you
know
i i'm walking down the street and i hear
some chilean music being played and i
never knew i like chili music but wow
so there is that side and i want them to
provide a limited but you know
interesting
place to go right and so don't try to
use your ai to kind of
you know figure me out and then put me
in a world where you figured me out
you know no create huge spaces for human
beings where our creativity and our
style will be enriched and come forward
and it'll be a lot more transparency i
won't have people
randomly anonymously putting comments up
and especially based on stuff they know
about me facts that you know we are so
broken right now if you're
you know especially if you're a
celebrity but you know it's about
anybody that
uh anonymous people are hurting lots and
lots of people right now and that's part
of this
thing that silicon valley is thinking
that you know just collect all this
information and use it in a great way so
no i i'm
i'm not i'm not a pessimism i'm very
much an optimist by nature but i think
that's just been the wrong path for the
whole technology to take
be more limited create let humans rise
up
don't don't try to replace them that's
the ai mantra don't try to
anticipate them don't try to predict
them because
you're you're not good at you're not
going to do those things you're going to
make things worse
okay so right now just give this a
chance
uh right now the recommender systems are
the creepy people in the shadow
watching your every move so they're
looking at traces of you
they're not directly interacting with
you sort of the
your close friends and family the way
they know you is by having conversation
by actually having interactions back and
forth
do you think there's a place for
recommender systems
sort of to step because you you just
emphasize the value of human to human
connection but yeah
just give it a chance ai human
connection is there a role for an ass
system to have conversations with you
in terms of to try to figure out what
kind of music you like not by just
watching what you're listening
but actually having a conversation
natural language or otherwise yeah no
i'm i'm so i'm not against it
i just want to push back against them
maybe you're saying you have options for
facebook so
there i think it's misplaced but but um
i think that this one
pending facebook yeah now so good for
you
um go for it that's a hard spot to be
yeah no good human interaction like on
our daily
the context around me in my own home is
something that i don't want some big
company to know about at all but i would
be more than happy to have technology
help me with it
which kind of technology well you know
just alexa amazon well a good
alexa's done right i think alex is a
research platform right now more than
anything else
but alexa done right you know could do
things like i
i leave the water running in my garden
and i say hey alex so the waters are in
my garden
um and even have alexa figure out that
that means when my wife comes home that
she should be told about that
that's a little bit of a reasoning i
call that ai and by any kind of stretch
it's a little bit of reasoning and it
actually kind of makes my life a little
easier and better
and you know i don't i wouldn't call
this a wow moment but i kind of think
that
overall rises human happiness up to have
that kind of thing
um but not when you're lonely alexa
knowing loneliness
no no there i don't want to let you that
be feel intrusive and i
and i don't want just the designer of
the system to kind of work all this out
i really want to have a lot of control
and i want transparency and control and
if the company can stand up and give me
that in the context of new technology
i think they're good first of all be way
more successful than our current
generation
and like i said i was mentioning
microsoft earlier i really think
they're pivoting to kind of be the
trusted old uncle but you know i think
that they get that this is the way to go
that if you let people
find technology empowers them to have
more control and have and have control
not just over privacy but over this rich
set of interactions
um that that people gonna like that a
lot more and that's that's the right
business model going forward
what does control over privacy look like
do you think you should be able to just
view
all the data that no it's much more than
that i mean first of all it should be an
individual decision
some people don't want privacy they want
their whole life out there other
people's want it um
privacy is not a zero one it's not a
legal thing it's not just about which
data is available which is not
um i like to recall to people that you
know
a couple hundred years ago everyone
there was not really big cities everyone
lived down the countryside and villages
um and in villages everybody knew
everything about you very you
didn't have any privacy is that bad are
we better off now
well you know arguably no because what
did you get for that loss of
at least certain kinds of privacy um
well uh
people helped each other if they because
they know everything about you they know
something's bad's happening they will
help you with that
right and now you live in a big city no
one knows their mouth you get no help
um so uh it kind of depends the answer i
want certain
people who i trust and there should be
relationships i should kind of manage
all those but
who knows what about me i should have
some agency there it shouldn't i
shouldn't
be a drift in a sea of technology where
i have no idea
i don't want to go reading things and
checking boxes
so i don't know how to do this and i'm
not a privacy researcher per se i just i
recognize the vast complexity of this
it's not just technology it's not just
legal scholars meeting technologists
there's got to be kind of
whole layers around it and so i when i
allude to this emerging engineering
field
this is a big part of it um like when
electrical engineering come
came i'm not wasn't around in the time
but you just didn't
plug electricity you know into walls and
it all kind of worked you don't have to
have like
underwriter's laboratory that reassured
you that that plug's not going to burn
up your house
and that that machine will do this and
that and everything there'll be whole
people who can install things there'll
be people who can watch the installers
there'll be a whole
layers you know an onion of these kind
of things and for things as deeply
interesting as privacy which is his
least essential electricity
um that that's gonna take decades to
kind of work out but it's gonna require
a lot of new structures that we don't
have right now so it's kind of hard to
talk about it
and you're saying there's a lot of money
to be made if you get it right so
absolutely
a lot of money to be made and all these
things that provide human services and
people recognize them as useful parts
of their lives uh so yeah um so yeah the
dialect sometimes goes from the
exuberant technologists
to the no technology is good kind of and
that's you know in our public discourse
you know in newspapers you see too much
of this kind of thing
and and the sober discussions in the
middle which are the challenging ones to
have are where we need to be having our
conversations
and you know there's not actually
there's not many forum forum for those
um you know there's that's that's kind
of what i would look for maybe i could
go and i could read a comment section of
something and it would actually be
this kind of dialogue going back and
forth you don't see much of this right
which is why actually there's a
resurgence of
podcasts out of all because good people
are really hungry for conversation
but their technology is not helping
much so comment sections of anything
including youtube
yeah is not hurting i'm not hurting yeah
and you think technically speaking it's
possible
to help i don't know the answers but
it's it's a it's a
less anonymity a little more locality um
you know worlds that you kind of enter
in and you trust the people there in
those worlds so that when you start
having a discussion you know
not only is that people not gonna hurt
you but it's not gonna be a total waste
your time
because there's a lot of wasting of time
that you know a lot of us i i pulled out
of facebook early on because it was
clearly going to waste a lot of my time
even though there was some value um and
so yeah
worlds that are somehow you enter in you
know what you're getting and it's kind
of
appeals to you might new things might
happen but you kind of have some
some trust in that world and there's
some
deep interesting complex psychological
aspects around anonymity
uh how that changes human behavior
indeed quite dark
and quite dark yeah i think a lot of us
are especially
those of us who really love the advent
of technology i loved social networks
when it came out i was just
i didn't see any negatives there at all
but then i started
uh seeing comment sections i think it
was maybe you know cnn or something
and i started going wow this this
darkness i just did not know
about and um and our technology is now
amplifying it
so sorry for the big philosophical
question but on that topic do you think
human beings because you've also out of
all things had
a foot in psychology too the
do you think human beings are
fundamentally good like
all of us have good intent that could be
mined
or is it depending on context and
environment
everybody could be evil thought my
answer is
fundamentally good um but fundamentally
limited
all of us have very you know blinkers on
we don't see the other person's pain
that easily we don't see the other
person's point of view that easily
we're very much in our own head in our
own world
and on my good days i think that
technology could open us up to you know
more perspectives and more less
blinkered and more understanding
you know a lot of wars in human history
happen because of just ignorance
they didn't they they thought the other
person was doing this well other person
wasn't doing this and we have huge
amounts of that
um but in my lifetime i've not seen
technology really help in that way
yet and i do i do i do believe in that
but
you know no i think fundamentally humans
are good the people suffer
people have grievances because you have
grudges and those things cause them to
do things they probably wouldn't want
they regret it often um so no i
i i think it's a you know part of the
progress of technology is to indeed
allow it
to be a little easier to be the real
good person you actually are
well but do you think individual human
life
or society could be modeled as an
optimization problem
um not the way i think typically i mean
that's your time
one of the most complex phenomena in the
whole you know in all
ways individual human life for society
as a whole both
both i mean individual human life is
amazingly complex and um
so uh you know optimization is kind of
just one branch of mathematics that
talks about certain kind of things and
uh it just
feels way too limited for the complexity
of such things
what properties of optimization problems
do you think so do you think most
interesting problems that could be
solved through optimization
uh what kind of properties does that
surface have non-convexity convexity
linearity
all those kinds of things saddle points
well so optimization's just one piece of
mathematics you know there's like you
just
even in our era we're aware that say
sampling
um is coming up with examples of
something um coming up with a
description
what's sampling well you they you can if
you're a kind of a certain kind of
mathematician you can try to blend them
and make them
seem to be sort of the same thing but
optimization is roughly speaking trying
to
uh find a point that um a single point
that is the
optimum of a criterion function of some
kind um
and sampling is trying to from that same
surface
treat that as a distribution or density
and find prop
points that have high density so um
i i want the entire distribution and the
sampling paradigm and i want the um
you know the the single point that's the
best point in the par in the sample
in the uh optimization paradigm now if
you were optimizing in the space of
probability measures
the output of that could be a whole
probability distribution so you can
start to make these things
the same but in mathematics if you go
too high up that kind of abstraction arc
you start to lose
the uh you know the ability to do the
interesting theorems so you kind of
don't try to you don't try to overly
over abstract so as a small tangent
what kind of world view do you find more
appealing one that is
deterministic or stochastic
well that's easy i mean i'm a
statistician you know the world is
highly stochastic wait i don't know
what's going to happen in the next five
minutes
right because you're going to ask what
we're going to do
massive uncertainty yeah you know
massive uncertainty and so the best i
can do is have come
rough sense or probability distribution
on things and somehow use that in my
reasoning about what to do
now so
how does the distributed at scale when
you have multi-agent systems
look like so optimization can optimize
sort of
it makes a lot more sense sort of uh at
least from
from a robotics perspective for a single
robot for a single agent trying to
optimize some objective function
when you start to enter the real world
this game theoretic concept starts
popping up
and that how do you see optimization in
this
because you've talked about markets in a
scale what does that look like
do you see this optimization do you see
it as sampling do you see
like how how should you modify these all
blend together um and a system designer
thinking about how to
build an incentivized system will have a
blend of all these things so
you know a particle in a potential well
is optimizing a function called
lagrangian
right the particle doesn't know that
there's no algorithm running
that does that it just happens it's so
it's a description mathematically of
something that helps us
understand as analysts what's happening
right and so the same will happen when
we talk about you know mixtures of
humans and computers
and markets and so on so forth there'll
be certain principles that allow us to
understand what's happening and whether
or not the actual algorithms are being
used by any sense
it's not clear now at some point i may
have set up a
multi-agent or market kind of system
and i'm now thinking about an individual
agent in that system
and they're asked to do some tasks and
they're incentivized in some way they
get certain signals and they
they have some utility maybe what they
will do at that point is they just won't
know the answer they may have to
optimize to find an answer
okay so an autism could be embedded
inside of an overall market
you know and game theory is is very very
broad it is often
studied very narrowly for certain kinds
of problems
but it's roughly speaking this is just
the i don't know what you're going to do
so i kind of anticipate that a little
bit
and you anticipate what i'm anticipating
and we kind of go back and forth in our
own minds we run kind of thought
experiments
you talked about this interesting point
in terms of game theory
you know most optimization problems
really hate
saddle points maybe you can describe
what saddle points are but
i've heard you kind of mentioned that
there's a there's a branch of
optimization
you could try to explicitly look for
saddle points
that's a good thing oh not optimization
that's just game theory that that's so
uh
there's all kinds of different
equilibria in game theory and some of
them are highly explanatory behavior
they're not attempting to be algorithmic
they're just trying to say if you happen
to be at this equilibrium
you would see certain kind of behavior
and we see that in real life that's what
an economist wants to do especially
behavioral economist
um uh in in continuous
uh differential game theory you're in
continuous spaces
a um some of the simplest equilibria are
saddle points a nash equilibrium is a
saddle point
it's a special kind of salon point so
classically in game theory you were
trying to find nash equilibria
and algorithmic games here you're trying
to find algorithms that would find them
and so you're trying to find saddle
points i mean so that's literally what
you're trying to do
um but you know any economist knows that
nash equilibria have their limitations
they are definitely not that explanatory
in many situations
they're not what you really want um
there's other kind of equilibria
and there's names associated with these
because they came from history with
certain people working on them but there
will be new ones emerging
so you know one example is a stackelberg
equilibrium
so you know nash you and i are both
playing this game against each other or
for each other maybe it's cooperative
and we're both going to think it through
and then we're going to decide and we're
going to off you know do our thing
simultaneously you know in a stackelberg
no i'm going to be the first mover i'm
going to make a move
you're going to look at my move and then
you're going to make yours now since i
know you're going to look at my move
i anticipate what you're going to do and
so i don't do something stupid
but and but then i know that you were
also anticipating me so we're kind of
going back and so far am i but there is
then a first mover
thing and so there's a those are
different equilibria
all right and uh so just mathematically
yeah these things have certain
topologies certain shapes they're like
southwest and algorithmically or
dynamically how do you move towards them
how do you move away from things
um you know so some of these questions
have answers they've been studied
others do not and especially if it
becomes stochastic
especially if there's large numbers of
decentralized things there's just uh you
know young people getting in this field
who kind of think it's all done because
we have you know tensorflow
well no these are all open problems and
they're really important and interesting
and it's about
strategic settings how do i collect data
suppose i don't know what you're going
to do because i don't know you very well
right well i got to kind of date about
you so maybe i want to push you in a
part of the space where i don't know
much about you so i can get data because
and then later i'll realize that you'll
never you'll never go there because of
the way the game is set up but you know
that's part of the overall
you know data analysis context is that
yeah even the game of poker is
fascinating space
whenever there's any uncertainty your
lack of information is it's a
super exciting space yeah uh just
uh lingard optimization for a second so
if we look at deep learning it's
essentially
minimization of a complicated loss
function
so is there something insightful or
hopeful that you see
in the kinds of function surface that
loss functions
that deep learning in in the real world
is trying to optimize over is there
something interesting
this is just the usual kind of problems
of optimization
i think from an optimization point of
view that surface first of all it's
pretty smooth
um and secondly if there's over if it's
over parameterized there's kind of lots
of paths down to reasonable optima
and so kind of the getting downhill to
the to an optimum is viewed as not as
hard as you might have expected
in high dimensions the fact that some
optima tend to be really good ones and
others not so good and you tend to it's
not
sometimes you find the good ones is sort
of still needs explanation
yes but but the particular surface is
coming from the particular generation of
neural nets i kind of suspect those will
this
those will change in 10 years it will
not be exactly those surfaces there'll
be some others that are
and optimization theory will help
contribute to why other surfaces are why
other algorithms
layers of arithmetic operations with a
little bit of nonlinearity
that's not that didn't come from
neuroscience per se i mean maybe in the
minds of some of the people working on
it they were thinking
about brains but uh they were arithmetic
circuits in all kinds of fields you know
uh computer science control theory and
so on
and that layers of these could transform
things in certain ways and that
if it's smooth maybe you could uh you
know find parameter values
um you know it's a big is a is
a sort of big discovery that it's it's
working it's able to work at this scale
but um
um i don't think that we're stuck with
that and we're certainly not stuck with
that because we're understanding the
brain
so in terms of uh on the algorithm size
of gradient descent
do you think we're stuck with gradient
descent this is uh variants of it what
variants do you find interesting or do
you think there'll be something else
invented
that uh is able to walk all over these
optimization spaces in more interesting
ways
so there's a co-design of the surface
and or the architecture and the
algorithm
so if you just ask if we stay with the
kind of architectures we have now and
not just neural nets but you know
phase retrieval architectures or
materials completion architectures and
so on
um you know i think we've kind of come
to a place where yeah
a stochastic gradient algorithms are
dominant
and um there are versions uh they're
you know that are a little better than
others they you know have more
guarantees they're more robust and and
so on and there's ongoing research to
kind of figure out which is the best
downforce situation
um but i think that that'll start to
co-evolve that that'll put pressure on
the actual architecture and so we
shouldn't do it in this particular way
we should do it in a different way
because this other algorithm is now
available if you do it in a different
way
um so uh
that that i can't really anticipate that
co-evolution process but
you know gradients are amazing uh
mathematical objects
um they uh have a lot of people who
uh start to study them more deeply
mathematically
are kind of shocked about what what they
are and what they can do um
i mean to think about this way if uh
suppose that i tell you if you move
along the x-axis you get uh
uh uh you know you go uphill in some
objective by you know three units
whereas if you move on the y-axis you go
uphill by
seven units right now i'm gonna only
allow you to move a certain you know
unit distance
all right what are you gonna do well the
most not people will say
i'm gonna go along the y-axis i'm
getting the biggest bang for my buck
you know and my buck is only one unit so
i'm gonna put all of it in the y-axis
right
and uh why should i even take any of my
strength my step size and put any of it
in the x-axis because i'm getting less
bang for my buck
that seems like a completely you know
clear cl
argument and it's wrong because the
gradient direction is not to go along
the y-axis
it's to take a little bit of the x-axis
uh and that
to understand that you have to you have
to know some math and
um so even a you know trivial so
so-called operator like grading is not
trivial and so
you know exploiting its properties is
still very very important um now we know
that just providing descent has got all
kinds of problems it gets stuck in many
ways and it hadn't have
you know good dimension dependence and
so on so um
my own line of work recently has been
about what kinds of stochasticity
how can we get dimension dependence how
can we do the theory of that
um and we've come up pretty favorable
results with certain kinds of
stochasticity
we have sufficient conditions generally
we know if you if you do this we will
give you a good guarantee
we don't have necessary conditions that
it must be done a certain way in general
so stochasticity how much randomness to
inject into the
into the walking along the gradient and
what kind of randomness
why is randomness good in this process
why is stochasticity good
yeah so um i give you simple answers but
in some sense again it's kind of amazing
stochasticity just
uh um you know particular features of a
surface that could have hurt you if you
were doing one thing
um deterministically it won't hurt you
because uh
you know by chance there's very little
chance that you would get hurt
and um you know so here stochasticity
um you know is just kind of
saves you from some of the particular
features of surfaces that
um you know and in fact if you think
about
you know surfaces that are discontinuous
in a first derivative like you know
absolute value function
um you will go down and hit that point
where there's non-differentiability
right and if you're running a
deterministic argument at that point you
can really do something bad
right whereas stochasticity just means
it's pretty unlikely that's going to
happen
you're going to you're going to hit that
point so you know
it's again not trivially analyzed but um
especially in higher dimensions also
stochasticity our intuition isn't very
good about it but it has
properties that kind of are very
appealing in high dimensions for a lot
of large number of reasons
um so it's it's all part of the
mathematics to kind of that's what's fun
to work in the field is that you get to
try to
understand this mathematics and um
but long story short you know partly
empirically it was discovered stochastic
gradient is very effective and
theory kind of followed i'd say um that
but
i don't see that we're getting clearly
out of that uh
what's the most beautiful mysterious a
profound idea
to you in optimization i don't know the
most
but let me just say that uh you know
nestorov's work on nest drive
acceleration to me
is uh pretty pretty surprising and
pretty deep
um can you elaborate well install
acceleration is just that um
i suppose that we are going to use
gradients to move around into space for
the reasons i've alluded to there there
are nice directions to move and suppose
that i tell you that you're only allowed
to use gradients
you're not going to be allowed to you'll
see this local person it can only sense
kind of a change in the surface
um but i'm going to give you kind of a
computer that's able to store all your
previous gradients and so you start to
learn
some something about the the surface um
and i'm going to restrict you to maybe
move in the direction of
like a linear span of all the gradients
so you can't kind of just move in some
arbitrary direction right
so now we have a well-defined
mathematical complexity model there's a
certain classes of algorithms that can
do that and others that can't
and we can ask for certain kinds of
surfaces how fast can you get down to
the optimum
so there's an answers to these so for a
you know a smooth
convex function there's an answer which
is one over the number of steps squared
you will be within a ball of that size
after after k steps um
gradient descent in particular has a
slower rate it's one over k
okay um so you could ask is gradient is
said actually even though we know it's a
good algorithm is it the best algorithm
in the sense of the answer is no
well well not clear yet because what
one of our case score is a lower bound
that's that's probably the best you can
do
what gradient is one over k but is there
something better
and so i think as a surprise to most
though nest drove discovered a new
algorithm
that is got two pieces to it it uses two
gradients
um and uh puts those together in a
certain kind of obscure way
and uh the thing doesn't even move
downhill all the time it sometimes goes
back uphill
and if you're a physicist that kind of
makes some sense you're building up some
momentum
and that is kind of the right intuition
but that that intuition is not enough to
understand kind of how to do it and why
it works
um but it does it achieves one over k
squared
and uh it has a mathematical structure
and it's still kind of
to this day a lot of us are writing
papers and trying to explore that and
understand it
um so there are lots of cool ideas in
optimization but just kind of using
gradients i think is number one that
goes back you know
150 years um and then nest drive i think
has made a major contribution with this
idea so like you said gradients
themselves are
in some sense mysterious yeah they're
not uh
they're not as trivial as they're not as
trivial coordinate descent
is more of a trivial one you just pick
one of the coordinates that's how we
think
that's our human mind that's our human
minds think and gradients are not
that easy for our human mind to grapple
with
an absurd question but uh what is
statistics
so the here it's a little bit it's
somewhere between math and science and
technology it's somewhere in that convex
hole so it's a
set of principles that allow you to make
inferences that have got some reason to
be believed
and also principles allow you make
decisions where you can
have some reason to believe you're not
going to make errors so all of that
requires some assumptions about what do
you mean by an error what do you mean by
you know the probabilities and um but
you know you start after you start
making some of those assumptions you're
led to
uh conclusions that yes i can guarantee
that you know
you know if you do this in this way your
probability of making error will be
small
your probability of continuing to not
make errors over time will be small
and probability you found something
that's real will be
small uh will be high so decision making
is a big part
of the big part yeah so uh the original
so statistics uh you know short history
was that you know it's kind of goes back
as a formal discipline you know 250
years or so it was called inverse
probability because around that era
probability was developed sort of
especially to explain gambling
situations of course and um interesting
so you would say well given the state of
nature is this there's a certain
roulette board that has a certain
mechanism in it
uh what kind of outcomes do i expect to
see uh and
um especially if i do things long long
amounts of time what outcomes i see and
the physicists start to pay attention to
this
um and then people say well given let's
turn the problem around what if i
saw certain outcomes could i infer what
the underlying mechanism was
that's an inverse problem and in fact
for quite a while statistics was called
inverse probability
that was the name of the field and i
believe
that uh it was laplace uh who was
working in napoleon's government who was
trying to who needed to do a census of
france learn about the people there so
he went and gathered data
and he analyzed that data to determine
policy and uh
said let's call this field that does
this kind of thing statistics because
um the the word state is in there in
french that's eta
but you know it's the study of data for
the state
so anyway that caught on and um it's
been called statistics ever since but um
uh but by the time it got formalized it
was sort of in the 30s
um and uh around that time there was
game theory and decision theory
developed
nearby people in that era didn't think
of themselves as either computer science
or statistics or controlled or econ they
were all
they were all the above and so you know
von neumann is developing game theory
but also
thinking of that as decision theory wall
is an econometrician
developing decision theory and then you
know turning that into statistics
and so it's all about here's a here's
not just data and you analyze it here's
a loss function here's what you care
about here's the question you're trying
to ask
here is a probability model and here's
the risk you will face
if you make certain decisions um and
to this day in most advanced statistical
curricula you teach decision theory is
the starting point
and then it branches out into the two
branches of bazin or frequentist but um
that's it's all about decisions in
statistics
what is the most beautiful
mysterious maybe surprising idea that
you've come across
uh yeah good question um
i mean there's a bunch of surprising
ones there's something that's way too
technical for this thing but something
called james stein estimation which is
kind of surprising
and really takes time to wrap your head
around can you try to maybe
i think i don't even want to try um let
me just say a colleague
at steve steven stickler at university
of chicago wrote a really beautiful
paper on james stein estimation which
helps to its views of paradox it kind of
defeats the mind's attempts to
understand it but
you can and steve has a nice perspective
on that
um there uh so one of the troubles with
statistics is that it's like in physics
that are in quantum physics you have
multiple interpretations there's a wave
and particle duality in physics and
you get used to that over time but it
still kind of haunts you that you don't
really
you know quite understand the
relationship the electrons away when
electrons a particle well
um well the same thing happens here
there's bayesian ways of thinking and
frequentist and they are different
they they all they sometimes become sort
of the same in practice
but they are physically different and
then in some practice they are not the
same at all they give you rather
different answers
um and so it is very much like wave and
particle duality and that is something
you have to kind of get used to in the
field
can you define beijing and frequencies
yeah in decision theory you can make
i have a like i have a video that people
could see it's called are you a bayesian
or a frequentist and kind of help
try to to make it really clear it comes
from decision theory so you know
decision theory
uh you're talking about loss functions
which are a function of
data x and parameter theta it's a
function of two arguments
okay neither one of those arguments is
known you don't know the data a priori
it's random and the parameter is unknown
all right so you have this function of
two things you don't know and you're
trying to say i want that function to be
small i want small loss
right well um what are you gonna do so
you sort of say well i'm gonna average
over these quantities
or maximize over them or something so
that you know
i turn that uncertainty into something
certain
so you could look at the first argument
an average over it or you could look at
the second argument average over it
that's bayesian frequencies so
the frequencies says i'm going to look
at the x the data
and i'm going to take that as random and
i'm going to average over the
distribution so i take the expectation
loss
under x theta is held fixed
all right that's called the risk and so
it's looking at other all the data sets
you could get
all right and say how well will a
certain procedure do under all those
data sets
that's called a frequency guarantee all
right so i think it is very appropriate
when like you're building a piece of
software and you're shipping it out
there and people are using all kinds of
data sets
you want to have a stamp a guarantee on
it that as people run it on many many
data sets that you never even thought
about that
95 of the time it will do the right
thing um perfectly reasonable
the bayesian perspective says well no
i'm going to look at the other argument
of the loss function the theta part
okay that's unknown and i'm uncertain
about it so i could have
my own personal probability for what it
is you know how many tall people are
there out there i'm trying to infer the
average height of the population well i
have an idea roughly what the height is
so i'm going to average over the um
the theta so now that loss function
has only now again one argument's gone
now it's a function of x and that's what
a bayesian does is they say well
let's just focus on the particular x we
got the data set we got we condition on
that
conditional on the x i say something
about my loss
that's a bayesian approach to things and
the bayesian
will argue that it's not relevant to
look at all the other data sets you
could have gotten
and average over them the frequentest
approach it's really
only the data set you got all right and
i do agree with that
especially in situations where you're
working with a scientist you can learn a
lot about the domain
and you really only focus on certain
kinds of data and you've gathered your
data and you make inferences
i don't agree with it though that it you
know in the sense that there are
needs for frequency guarantees you're
writing software people are using it out
there you want to say something so these
two things have to go out to fight each
other a little bit but they have to
blend
so long story short there's a set of
ideas that are right in the middle
they're called empirical bays
and empirical base sort of starts with
the bayesian framework
it's it's kind of arguably
philosophically more
you know reasonable and kosher write
down a bunch of the math that kind of
flows from that
and then realize there's a bunch of
things you don't know because it's the
real world then you don't
know everything so you're uncertain
about certain quantities at that point
ask is there a reasonable way to plug in
an estimate for those things
okay and in some cases there's quite a
reasonable thing to do
to plug in there's a natural thing you
can observe in the world that you can
plug in
and then do a little bit more
mathematics and assure yourself it's
really good
so my math are based on human expertise
what's
what are good they're both going in the
bayesian framework allows you to put a
lot of human expertise in
but the math kind of guides you along
that path and then kind of reassures you
at the end you could put that stamp of
approval under certain assumptions
this thing will work so perhaps you
asked question what's my favorite you
know or what's the most surprising nice
idea so
one that is more accessible is something
called false discovery rate
which is um you know you're making not
just one hypothesis test or making one
decision you're making a whole bag of
them
and in that bag of decisions you look at
the ones where you made a discovery you
announced that something interesting it
happened
all right that's gonna be some subset of
your big bag
in the ones you made a discovery which
subset of those are bad
there are false false discoveries you
like the fraction of your false
discoveries among your discoveries to be
small
that's a different criterion than
accuracy or precision or recall or
sensitivity and specificity it's it's a
different quantity
those latter ones are almost all of them
um
have more of a frequencies flavor they
say given the truth
is that the null hypothesis is true
here's what accuracy i would get
or given that the alternative is true
here's what i would get so it's kind of
going forward from the state of nature
to the data the bayesian goes the other
direction from the data back to the
state of nature
and that's actually what false discovery
rate is it says given you made a
discovery
okay that's condition on your data
what's the probability of the hypothesis
it's going the other direction and so um
the classical frequency look at that so
i can't know that there's some priors
needed in that
and the empirical bayesian goes ahead
and plows forward and starts writing
down
these formulas and realizes at some
point some of those things can actually
be estimated in a reasonable way oh
and so it's kind of it's a beautiful set
of ideas so i i this kind of line of
argument has come out
it's not certainly mine but it it sort
of came out from
robin's around 1960. uh brad ephron has
written beautifully about this in
various papers and books and uh
and the fdr is you know ben yamini
in israel um john storey did this
bayesian interpretation
and so on so i've just absorbed these
things over the years and find it a very
healthy way to think about
statistics let me ask you about
intelligence to jump slightly back out
into philosophy perhaps you said that
uh maybe you can elaborate but uh you
said that defining just even the
question of what is intelligence is a
word is as a very difficult question is
that a useful question
do you think we'll one day understand
the fundamentals of human intelligence
and what it means
you know have good uh benchmarks for
general intelligence that we put before
our machines
so i don't work on these topics so much
you're really asking a question
for a psychologist really and i just
studied some but i don't consider myself
at least an expert at this point you
know a psychologist aims to understand
human intelligence right and i think
many psychologists i know are fairly
humble about this
they they might try and understand how a
baby understands you know whether
something's a solid or liquid or
uh whether something's hidden or not and
um
maybe how you know a child starts to
learn the meaning of certain words
what's a verb what's a noun and also you
know
slowly but surely trying to figure out
things
um but human's ability to take a really
complicated environment reason about it
abstract about it find the right
abstractions communicate about it
interact and so on is just you know
really
staggeringly rich and complicated
um and so you know i think in all
humidity we don't
think we're kind of aiming for that in
the near future certainly psychologists
doing experiments with babies in the lab
or with people talking is is
has a much more limited aspiration and
you know conor mcversky would look at
our reasoning patterns and they're
they're not deeply understanding
all the how we do our reasoning but
they're sort of saying here's some
here's some oddities about the reasoning
and some things you should you need to
think about it but also i as i emphasize
and things
some things i've been writing about um
you know ai the revolution hasn't
happened yet
yeah um great blog post i've i've been
emphasizing that
you know if you step back and look at uh
intelligent systems of any kind
whatever you mean by intelligence it's
not just the humans or the animals or
you know the plants or whatever you know
so a market that brings goods into a
city you know food to restaurants or
something every day
uh is a system it's a decentralized set
of decisions
looking at it from far enough away it's
just like a collection of neurons
everyone every neuron is making its own
little
decisions presumably in some way and if
you step back enough
every little part of an economic system
is making us all of its decisions
and just like with the brain who knows
what the individual neuron doesn't know
what the overall goal is
right but something happens at some
aggregate level same thing with the
economy
people eat in a city and it's robust it
works at all scales small villages to
big cities
it's been working for thousands of years
uh it works rain or shine so it's
adaptive
um so all kind of you know those are
adjeeves one tends to
apply to intelligent systems robust
adaptive you know you don't need to keep
adjusting it it's self self healing
whatever plus not perfect you know
intelligences are never perfect and
markets are not perfect
um but i do not believe in this area
that you cannot that you can say well
our computers our humans are smart but
you know
no markets are not more markets are so
they are intelligent
uh now um we humans didn't evolve to be
markets we've been participating in them
right
but we are not ourselves a market per se
um the neurons could be viewed as the
market you can't
there's economic you know neuroscience
kind of perspectives that's interesting
to
pursue all that the point though is is
that if you were to study humans and
really be
the world's best psychologist study for
thousands of years and come up with the
theory of human intelligence you might
have never discovered
principles of markets you know spy
demand curves and
you know matching and auctions and all
that uh those are real principles and
they lead to a form of intelligence
that's not
maybe human intelligence it's arguably
another kind of intelligence
there probably are third kinds of
intelligence or fourth that none of us
are really thinking too much about right
now
so if you really and then all those are
relevant to computer systems
in the future certainly the market one
is relevant right now
whereas understand human intelligence is
not so clear that it's relevant right
now probably not
um so if you want general intelligence
whatever one means by that or you know
understand the intelligence in a deep
sense and all that it is definitely
has to be not just human intelligence
it's got to be this broader thing
and that's not a mystery markets are
intelligent so you know
it's definitely not just a philosophical
stance to say we gotta move beyond and
tell who intelligence that sounds
ridiculous
yeah but it's not and in that blog post
you define different kinds of like
intelligent infrastructure iii which i
really like that's some of the concept
you've just been
describing do you see ourselves if we
see earth
human civilization is a single organism
do you think the intelligence of that
organism
when you think from the perspective of
markets and intelligence infrastructure
is
increasing is it increasing linearly is
it increasing exponentially
what do you think the future of that
intelligence i don't know i don't tend
to think i don't
tend to answer questions like that
because you know that's science fiction
hoping to catch you off guard
well again because you said it's so far
in the future
it's fun to ask and you'll probably
you know like you said predicting the
future is really
nearly impossible but say
as an axiom one day we create
a human level superhuman level
intelligent not the scale of markets but
the scale of an
individual what do you think is
is what do you think it would take to do
that or maybe to ask another question
is how would that system be different
than the biological human beings that we
see
around us today is it possible to say
anything interesting to that question or
is it just a stupid question
it's not stupid question but it's
science fiction science fiction and so
i'm totally happy to read science
fiction and think about it from time my
own life
i loved there was this like brain in a
vat kind of you know little thing that
people were talking about when i was a
student i remember
you know imagine that uh um you know
between
your brain and your body there's you
know there's a bunch of wires right
and suppose that every one of them was
replaced with a uh
uh literal wire and then suppose that
wire was turning actually a little
wireless
you know there's a receiver and sender
so the brain has got all the
senders and receiver you know on all of
its exiting uh
you know axons and all the dendrites
down the body have
replaced with syndrome receivers now you
could move the body off somewhere and
put the brain in a vat
right and then you could do things like
start killing off those centers of
receivers one by one
and after you've killed off all of them
where is that person you know they
thought they were out in the body
walking around the world and they moved
on so those are science fiction things
those are fun to think about it's just
intriguing about where's what is thought
where is it and all that
and i think every 18 year old it's to
take philosophy classes and think about
these things
and i think that everyone should think
about what could happen in society
that's kind of bad and all that but i
really don't think that's the right
thing for most of us that are my age
group to be doing and thinking about
i really think that we have so many more
present
you know first challenges and dangers
and
real things to build and all that um
such that uh
you know uh spending too much time on
science fiction at least in public fora
like this i think is is
not what we should be doing maybe over
beers in private that's right
i'm well welcome welcome i'm not gonna
broadcast where i have beers because
this is gonna go on facebook
a lot of people showing up there but um
yeah
i'll uh i love facebook twitter amazon
youtube i have i'm optimistic and
hopeful
but uh maybe maybe i don't have grounds
for such optimism and hope
let me ask term you've mentored
some of the brightest sort of some of
the seminal figures in the field
can you uh give advice
to people who undergraduates today what
does it take to take
you know advice on their journey if
they're interested in machine learning
and ai in in
the ideas of markets from economics and
psychology and all the kinds of things
that you're exploring
what what what steps should they take on
that journey well yeah first of all the
door is open and second it's a journey i
like your language there
uh it is not that you're so brilliant
and you have great brilliant ideas and
therefore that's that's just
you know that's how you have success or
that's how you enter into the field
uh it's that you apprentice yourself you
you spend a lot of time you work on hard
things you
try and pull back and you be as broad as
you can you talk lots of people
um and it's like entering any kind of a
creative community there's um years that
are needed
and uh human connections are critical to
it so you know i think about
you know being a musician or being an
artist or something you don't just
you know immediately from day one you
know you you're a genius and therefore
you do it no you
um you know practice really really hard
on basics
and you uh be humble about where you are
and then and you realize you'll never be
an expert on everything so you kind of
pick and there's a lot of randomness and
a lot of kind of
luck but luck just kind of picks out
which
branch of the tree go down but you'll go
down some branch um
so yeah it's it's a community so the
graduate school is
i still think is one of the wonderful
phenomena that we have in our in our
world it's it's very much about
apprenticeship with an advisor it's very
much about a group of people you belong
to
it's a four or five year process so it's
plenty of time to start from kind of
nothing to come up to something you know
more expertise and then start to have
your own creativity start to flower even
surprise into your own self um and it's
a very cooperative endeavor it's i think
a lot of people uh think of
science as highly competitive and i
think in some other fields it might be
more so
here it's way more cooperative than you
might imagine
and people are always teaching each
other something and people are always
more than happy to
uh be clear that so i i feel i'm an
expert on certain kind of things
but i'm very much not expert on lots of
other things and a lot of them are
relevant
and a lot of them are i should know but
it should in some sense i you know
you don't so um i'm always willing to
reveal my ignorance to people around me
so they can teach me things
and uh i think a lot of us feel that way
about our field so it's very cooperative
uh i might add it's also very
international because it's so
cooperative we see no barriers
and uh so that the nationalism that you
see especially in the current era and
everything is just
at odds with the way that most of us
think about what we're doing here where
this is a human endeavor and we we
cooperate and
are very much trying to do it together
for the you know
the benefit of everybody so last
question
where and how and why did you learn
french
and which language is more beautiful
english or french
um great question so um first of all i
think italian's actually more beautiful
than french and english and i also speak
that so i'm i'm
i'm married to an italian and i have
kids and we speak italian
um anyway though all kidding aside that
every language allows you to express
things a bit differently um
and it is one of the great fun things to
do in life is to explore those things so
in fact when i kids or you know teens or
uh college students ask me what they
just
study i say well do what your heart
where your heart is certainly do a lot
of math math is good for everybody
but do some poetry and do some history
and do some language too
um you know throughout your life you'll
want to be a thinking person you'll
want to have done that um for me
uh yeah french i learned when i was i'd
say
a late teen um i was living in the
middle of the country
in kansas and uh not much was going on
in kansas with all due respect to kansas
but
uh and so my parents happen to have some
french books on the shelf and just in my
boredom i
pulled them down and i found this is fun
and i kind of learned the language by
reading
and when i first heard it spoken i had
no idea what was being spoken but i
realized i
somehow knew it from some previous life
and so i made the connection
um but then you know i traveled and just
i i love to go beyond my own barriers
and uh
my own comfort or whatever and i found
myself in you know on trains in france
next to
say older people who would you know live
the whole life of their own and
the ability to communicate with them was
was you know special
and uh ability to also see myself in
other people's shoes and have empathy
and kind of work on that language as
part of that
um so um so after
that kind of experience um and also
embedding myself in french culture which
is you know
quite quite amazing you know languages
are rich not just because there's
something
inherently beautiful about it but it's
all the creativity that went into it so
i learned a lot of songs read poems read
books
um and then i was here actually at mit
where we're doing the
podcast today and uh young professor
um you know not yet married and uh
um you know not having a lot of friends
in the area so i just didn't have i
was getting kind of a bored person i
said i heard a lot of italians around
there's happened to be a lot of italians
at mit
behind professor for some reason and so
i was kind of vaguely understanding what
they were talking about i said well i
should learn this language too so i
i did and then later met my spouse and
uh
you know wow italian became a more
important part of my life but um but i
go to china a lot these days i go to
asia i go to europe and um every time i
go i kind of
uh i'm amazed by the richness of human
experience and the the
people don't have any idea if you
haven't traveled kind of how i'm you
know amazingly rich and i love
the diversity it's not just a buzzword
to me it really means something i love
the
you know you know embed myself with
other people's experiences and uh so
yeah learning language is a big part of
that i think i've said in some
interview at some point that if i had
you know millions of dollars on the
infinite time whatever what would you
really work on if you really wanted to
do ai and for me that is natural
language
and really done right you know deep
understanding of language
um that's to me an amazingly interesting
scientific challenge
and uh when we're very far away one
we're very far away but good natural
language people are kind of really
invested then i think a lot of them see
that's where the core of ai is that if
you understand that you really help
human communication
you understand something about the human
mind the semantics that come out of the
human mind
and i agree i think that will be such a
long time so i didn't do that in my
career just because i kind of
i was behind in the early days i didn't
kind of know enough of that stuff i was
at mit i didn't learn much
language and it was too late at some
point to kind of spend a
whole career doing that but i admire
that field and uh
um and so in my little way by learning
language
you know kind of that part of my brain
has um has been trained up
jan was right you truly are the miles
davis and machine learning i
don't think there's a better place than
it was mike is a huge honor talking to
you today merci beaucoup
all right it's been my pleasure thank
you thanks for listening to this
conversation with michael
i jordan and thank you to our presenting
sponsor cash app
download it use code lex podcast you'll
get ten dollars
and ten dollars will go to first an
organization that inspires and educates
young minds
to become science and technology
innovators of tomorrow
if you enjoy this podcast subscribe on
youtube give it five stars on apple
podcast
support it on patreon or simply connect
with me on twitter
at lex friedman and now
let me leave you with some words of
wisdom from michael i jordan
from his blog post titled artificial
intelligence
the revolution hasn't happened yet
calling
for broadening the scope of the ai field
we should embrace the fact that what we
are witnessing
is the creation of a new branch of
engineering the term engineering is
often invoked in a narrow sense
in academia and beyond with overtones of
cold
effectless machinery and negative
connotations of loss of control by
humans
but an engineering discipline can be
what we want it to be
in the current era we have a real
opportunity to conceive of something
historically new
a human-centric engineering discipline
i'll resist giving this emerging
discipline a name but if the acronym ai
continues to be used let's be aware of
the very real limitations of this
placeholder
let's broaden our scope tone down the
hype
and recognize the serious challenges
ahead
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you